welcome to this video playing lucky guy
grin was the lucky guy from Vietnam is
this that now no take-backs okay I'm
fine with that there is no take back
anyway here are they stand back you can
hear you can you can actually go and
take back in five minutes sorry wrong um
let's see and it also makes sense to
allow take-backs basically if you really
have a J obvious mouse libram against
yeah and you know each other whatever
your needs of course quite nice to to
give or take back so what do we have we
have a same ish Kings Indian this line
with d5 and d4 edits I have some issues
with that I don't really get any good
positions maybe I can play here and give
away the depart for the moment getting
it back with should be too okay so now
we get this closed type of center which
I don't mind at all
let's see you or if I get in a g4 H for
this stuff then why this is an excellent
shape you will probably do something
against that like trying to locate all
this this is a very drastic way to do it
okay h4 g4 h5 looks looks quite good in
my book but for white I mean the h6 porn
is Sam is a weakness now this should be
three Queen d2 yeah maybe maybe you can
just plain ig8 it does not look like
like much but probably you need to to
cover age 67 somehow okay so you just
wants to casts a long and give give away
the pond yeah maybe maybe that's the way
to do it I still don't have any anything
else really just then attacking it and
grabbing it um maybe if I take it now 98
and night sorry Matty to g8 and then you
will take it and I should probably
protect h5 beforehand can you can only
defend I know you cannot even defend age
6
hmm interesting
maybe I can take it and Bishop g5 then
use the h-bond possible aha so f5 or
what I fiber but f5 i take i just take
that ok I need to I need to grab here
anyway I guess um maybe can suck the
exchange like Quincy three yeah well you
have start to calculate all this but I'm
going to lose on time every game
oh yeah well I can take it and I must
take it now an f4 I cannot really allow
this move g3 or whatever I mean okay
it's it's it's reasonably complicated
but I don't really think that this is
working yep
yeah it's still it's still messy this
position but it's like the type of stuff
that if you give it to a computer at
will in Hungary hundred games out of 100
with white but it's so not not easy to
do for a human must take at least a band
in blitz and for me but it looks very
good for why do I go Queen g5 checking
on f5 and intending Bishop g7 and h6
sorry let's do that trying to play with
the temple not losing any time the H
porn is my wet drop card here ok now
rook g8 this is really a threat ok
should I give this check probably check
then King back to f2 this looks
reasonably coordinated and I have
protected c4 for the time being rook g8
I go Queen to h4
yeah that's probably a probably really
good I'm still skeptical because my king
is a bit a bit loose but at the moment
there is no nothing serious threatened
on this Queen age for right here don't
know
I would like I for I can maybe play your
form not sure how this I didn't see
let's come to the oil this check
possible check here 22 look yogi to if
it takes on on c3 I can push the edge
porn
and even sure what I do if he takes f3 I
will just take what the King go to e2
okay rook g1 is not possible III Hanks
okay so look age 32 g 3 maybe something
like that
yeah it's still tricky
well I defend with all pieces and it's
not so clear that the bishop is helping
much I mean probably I should be winning
yet it's not like I can relax here Queen
a four men you checking d6 also time
morning check 27 why it's got this check
ok over here Queen here so we'll be too
trying to play for opiate getting
getting one look traded I think I don't
see it don't see anything really Queen
d2 rookie to and he's out of checks
rookie form I can take it only for all
right there is no check I don't see a
check a good age to cover dish for that
for FX on time yeah it's it's over yeah
this was house still somewhat hairy
because of the somewhat open King
position I mean a computer would would
easily win it but it's not so easy to
inland in blitz chess not sure if I
allowed something up it's very much
possible you know this all this here he
goes efore the computer is a quite
optimistic for black yeah I am hmm it's
it looks tricky if I take Rukia Jedi
even even lose and suddenly all pieces
attack okay I need to do something else
I'm not sure what actually
this and then efore was the good move
okay yeah let's see if I allowed
anything here but I'm reasonably
optimistic i thought it looked like
check okay who gave aid was was easier
but i think i'm always yeah computer
says i'm winning and care and they
didn't allow anything much yeah it was
quite weird and this this what he did
here with the g5 i found really strange
positionally allowing this age five
here's a scene f4 f4 and that's that
would have been would have been even
better to be honest it would have been
even better he's in a bit of a strange
spot here because I'm yeah I threatened
to take at a very unappropriate moment
when he needs to recapture with the pawn
96 there is h5 and this is totally
terrible with those two to ricky's f4
was even stronger h5 is quite ok but
it's not so decisive he can play that
it's not it's not totally crazy but I
understand that he wanted to play a more
active late not sure that it is so it is
working now computer once rook AG one
yeah okay well I'm not a comp and 28 it
is probably the type of position that it
is that is mathematically winning but so
tricky in a practical game alright
thanks for watching